uh good evening everyone i see
everyone's filing in
i see some names as we go by see jason
harlan paul
georgette's here it's good to see some
familiar names uh
too many i've already lost track of all
the names of the people i've seen
before but it's good to have everyone
here we'll just give a few moments as
everyone logs in
i see michael there's a lot of michaels
though i see mike and michael a lot of
you i know there's somebody the same
name i'm just gonna say mike and michael
let's see who else do we have here um
good to see everyone we have tom
good to see everyone coming in here and
again we'll give everyone just a few
moments to uh file in as the
waiting room opens up and we get
everyone situated
very excited everyone hope everyone's
summer is going well we have katarina
and clifford coming in
hope everyone's having a nice start to
the summer unless you happen to be
coming from the southern hemisphere in
which case i hope you're enjoying your
winter
i know we do often have people from the
southern hemisphere so hope everyone's
enjoying whatever season you're in
but we'll do it that way all right
so oh dusty's here good to see you too
and let's see i don't get to see anybody
it really
really sucked hopefully soon enough we
will be seeing each other in person
so first things first people who used to
come in person back when that was a
thing
you all know that i like to always start
to meet up with who is hiring
of course we can't exactly do that right
now because i can't
in fact it's not even capable of people
jumping here and shout so i'd like
everyone to do
if you're looking to hire someone go
into the nyhakar slack
and in the job postings channel host
your job
this meetup has been great for the past
11 years
getting people jobs as you know 12 years
now it's been great at getting people
jobs uh all throughout the years but
there's some people here in the chat
room who i know got jobs through the
meetup
i'm talking a decade ago i know they got
jobs so if you want to hire someone one
of these many talented people at this
group
go to the job postings channel and post
your job there and
make sure you include a link so people
can apply we'd love to have as many
people here
getting more jobs as possible um one of
the
uh lucky things for me is that since i
am on screen i get to announce that i am
hiring
i'll take that opportunity i'm hiring
three roles
we are looking for a data scientist a
salesperson
and a linux sysadmin with um
familiarity with mostly ubuntu but red
hat's useful also
so if you're looking for any of these
three roles data scientist sales or
linux system talk to me you know how to
find me
find me on slack buy me an email find me
on twitter find me
anywhere i'm earning easy to find so
everyone post jobs next up
those of you who've been coming in
person and even the past few years
virtually know that we're all about the
pizza here mine has not arrived yet so i
have this beautiful slice
coming from dominic's pizza right here i
hold it upside down to show you the
cheese law i'll show you the bottom
um hope everyone's enjoying the pizza
you have wherever you have it coming
from
sound off in the chat let me know where
you got your pizza from or your other
snack that you're having instead of
pizza because you're like
that's cool a few other events we have
coming up where there will all be pizza
involved because you know
you folks know how i am uh starting
tomorrow and it's
uh sold out um but i like telling people
about it we do it every year
the stan workshop we've been doing this
for i want to say like
seven years or something it's been a
very long time
it's um uh it's a three-day workshop
with the team behind the stand language
to do a bayesian analysis journal
gabriel is going to be leading
and we have andrew gellman appearing and
rob trangucci and scott spencer all
coming to teach this class we do it
every year and the money goes
for further stand development so we are
very excited for that
we'll do it again next year and maybe
sometime in between that is sold out but
we are excited to be doing it
um i see this question i think from sean
about cheese lock what cheese lock is
um so everybody just slice the pizza and
the cheese comes sliding right off it's
not attached
cheese lock is where the cheese stays in
place
and believe it or not the big pizza
chains do a lot of like chemical
research about
this to figure out how they're going to
make it work and smaller pizzerias often
do it by having here go to pizzeria
where you can see the sauce
that allows the water to evaporate
meaning the cheese will hold on tight
so there's cheese lock for you
next month still virtual we have our
meetup i don't have the date
yet because i forgot to write it down we
have a date i forgot to write it down
though
ian cook will be giving a talk uh so
we're very excited to have ian cook
virtually with us in august we will be
announcing that
hopefully by friday maybe by monday but
either way stay tuned
august someday in august we will be
doing that
then september we are really really
really excited for september
it is our return to live at least
partially depending what we could find
i'll explain it all
so we have our seventh annual
new york r conference coming up
september 9th
and 10th it's gonna be two days are fun
we have some
really great speakers um some of them
are even this room right now
virtually in this room uh speaking as
you've heard of it's gonna be a really
fun time
um september 9th through 10th
we have workshops associated with that
conference
on september 1st this is the first year
we split it across
two different weeks uh so workshops
from the likes of david robinson malcolm
barrett
lucy d'agostino i'm forgetting her last
name i'm sorry lucy if you're here i
forgot your last name
cass akimoto your own yansons we have a
bunch of really fun cool good people
giving workshops on september 1st
and the conference on september 9th and
10th
we also are trying to host an in-person
meetup september 1st
but unlike the conference it is very
hard to get a space to hold us for the
meetup
because a lot of offices are not really
set with their opening plans
so if you have a space that can hold
about 100 people on september 1st or 2nd
we would love to hold the our conference
they are meet up there that week to
coincide with the workshops in the
conference
so if you have an office space or a
venue or any sort of space that can hold
about 100 people
send me a message right away because we
would love to have someone host
us if you are looking to attend the
conference
and just about any event we put on
through this meetup group and you want
to attend
use the code ny hack r for a
20 discount any event that we organized
you could use the code in my hack r
because the events we organized are
really for this group
you'll get a code but you'll get a
discount 20 by using code and one hack r
um i see in the chat that nicole posted
uh the next meetup is august 12th with
ian cook and if you want to go and get
tickets for the
workshop and the conference you can do
so at rstats.ai
and by the way the conference it's in
person but it's also
virtual so for some reason you're living
somewhere you can't attend or don't feel
comfortable attending
you could watch it virtually it's going
to use a platform called hop in like we
used this past year for the virtual
events it would be really great
for those of you worried about
attendance again if you're not don't
feel comfortable
do it virtually but we are following the
guidelines of broadway
broadway is fully opening in september
and i thought if broadway can do it
we can absolutely do it too and for
those of you that have attended before
it is in a much bigger space it's gonna
be much more physically comfortable
you can spread out more it's going to be
it's going to be a lot of fun it's going
to be really great
so for tonight's meetup we obviously
can't ask questions as we go
um we can't you can't just all shout now
so if you have a question for sean and i
hope there will be a lot of questions
do your best to stump them that's our
goal today we want to stump sean
right uh post them in either the chat
you see
right here and zoom or in the meetup
in the meet up slack i'm going to post a
link directly to the channel
in slack i hope this works oh i gotta
send it to the right clear hold on
if you send it to that you click that
link that should take you right to the
meetup channel
it is called monthly meetup chat and
it's inside the ny hacker slack
so you have questions ask it in there
ask it and zoom
and at the end of the talk i will
collate the questions and ask out of
sean
all right and we are hoping that we're
gonna have a lot of good questions a lot
of fun
and uh because this is a very fun topic
right now we have
so with that we have um the
question from um there is a question
coming in about fully faster anyone can
attend
we are following cdc guidelines and new
york rules about
gatherings and from as far as we can
tell the conferences
it's open to anybody whatever broadway's
doing is what we're doing okay
just to keep it safe that way but we'll
follow the rules as they exist um
regardless of my proclivities um
but you want everyone to be saved that's
the most important thing
so we have a speaker who's been a long
time member of the meetup he used to
live
in new york came to meet ups a lot spoke
in the meetups spoke at the conference
i'm not sure even how many times you've
spoken at all of our events i think it's
been multiple between everything
um so i'm very excited to have this very
hot topic puzzle imprints it's so hot
right now
and i'd like to invite sean to the stage
to give us a rousing talk
i'll virtually pause for you
thanks jared really happy to be here
excited to be back i think the last talk
was actually quite a long time ago so
um so you're overdue it's definitely
overdue
try to get slides cued up here
all right so this is sort of like a
pretty personal
talk for me because um i'm now about 10
years
into my like official career as a data
scientist and um
and i i was trained in i did grad school
in new york at nyu
and i was trained with economist so i
hung around with a bunch of
economists and they have a certain
aesthetic for causal inference
and basically it's that like we can't
even publish something if it's not
identified
and that's a that's a pretty strong
perspective and then so then i had like
10 years of
working on practical problems at
companies like facebook and lyft
and and hearing about other data
scientists at other companies and what
they're working on
and trying to figure out like when am i
supposed to apply this tool like should
i be as
you know rigid as those economists are
or you know should i sort of like be
more open-minded about
when you know when is the right time to
use these tools and so
i think it's a really interesting topic
to think about and it's very personal to
me because i've become sort of this like
causal inference guy people associate me
with forecasting from profit and then
also now
with with causal inference and and i
have a very nuanced perspective on it i
don't think it's like
i'm not like a kool-aid drinker in any
way i think that there's actually like a
lot of interesting
uh reasons to use it and then not to use
it so that's that's the spirit of this
talk is to be like
intellectually critical of these ideas
and try to kind of explore
when when should we be thinking this way
and when should we be thinking in
different ways
all right so just to preview like my
answer to this question
is like there's two provocative answers
that you could give like one is that you
always need
cousin prince and the other one is never
and i'm gonna i'm gonna do both
so uh that's that's the spirit of the
talk is that i'm gonna try to like take
both both perspectives and you know
there's a little bit of intellectual
rigmarole to
to make them both fit but in the always
section i'm going to make the claim that
useful all models are wrong but some are
useful useful models are ones that tell
us what we should
do and um telling you something useful
involves like having a causal model it
just it just has to
and because you have to do something as
a result of what the model says and you
have to model what the result of that is
going to be
so in the always case it's basically
about pragmatism
and pragmatism yields sort of like a a
setup where we always need causal
inference because we're always trying to
make something happen
um in the never section i think i'm
gonna it's gonna be even more
provocative i'm gonna take a sort of
like strong stance on causal inferences
just a tool
and so like you know maybe there are
lots of cases where we don't need it and
in fact like maybe all of the useful
cases are the ones where we can
estimate what we could have estimated
using cause and reference tools through
other means
and so this this is maybe a little more
provocative than the first section but i
think like you know
also has a lot of pragmatism associated
with it from from my experience working
in industry
all right first section we always need
causal inference
so to start this section i want to
introduce my the data scientist best
friend
which is the conditional expectation
function
you may know this as scikit-learn or
pytorch or keras or whatever you know
your preferred
function fitter is but uh we use it all
the time in data science this is the
workhorse
technology of data science and i'm going
to completely abstract away like the
implementation details of how we how we
get this thing
um but we use it all the time even when
you do tabular data like you know you do
a group by and you
compute means that's what a that's a
conditional expectation function too
we're always conditioning on things and
always trying to estimate something from
the data so
so this is like a a thing that we're
going to continue to build on top
of but assuming your job is to make one
of these functions
and just like for the venture
capitalists in the audience this this is
like
this function and its existence and
usefulness like suggests
a set of businesses that you should
invest in it's like feature stores
provide s's
metric stores provide y's we like train
models and produce the hats on the e's
and then like we store and serve the
models so um you could you know all
these things should work together and
they're all pain points for data
scientists almost everybody could relate
to like one of these problems being a
big pain in the ass
so when you work on conditional
expectation functions all to live a long
day there's a sort of like set of
problems that you run into like as a as
a data scientist and i think they sort
of
there's a journey of of of things that
you hit so when you're early in your
career you think oh i need
i'm not using the right language maybe
i'm not i should be using python instead
of r or
stata doesn't work for this particular
thing then you get on to like you know
caring about packages
or tuning hyper parameters or better
feature engineering is like you know
you're climbing up the hierarchy of
needs
and then like i think really enlightened
people are like i just need better data
data i have is adequate for the problem
that i want to solve
and i i have lately been really
interested in model evaluation i think
it's really hard and probably like even
even after you have all this stuff do
you know if you have a good model was
pretty hard question to answer
but at the very end of that is like you
just have a model right you don't have
you haven't done anything you haven't
made anything happen in the world um
and so like you need the model to make
something good happen and so
conditional expectation functions are
just a tool for
like enacting some kind of like outcome
that you would like to see in
in the real world and so the next three
sections of this talk i'm going to give
stories of like you know how the model
can actually make something happen in
in different sort of like data science
context
so story number one is about term
prediction it's sort of like almost like
a
this is like hello world for for data
scientists so what does this model look
like
uh well first we have like a label
which is like you know maybe the user
cancels their account or we haven't seen
them in 30 days or whatever
and then you know like s is just
anything it's anything in your database
so you can compute
you can create all these features about
what they've been doing recently and
you're going to build some great model
sorry i'm getting a bunch of chats i
just want to make sure i'm not
okay positive feedback good
all right so we have this model we
fitted it
awesome going to use this uh and then
like there's
there's a theory that you have when you
build a model like this right you you
were like
you are doing the underpants gnomes
business model of like
you have a model there's some step where
someone's gonna do something about
the model using the model and then
you're gonna like make more money
and it's very actually reasonable theory
because you could just send them coupons
and everyone's got this idea like
what are we going to do with the term
prediction model we're going to like do
something about the scores
and then there's going to be like a
great business win there because we're
going to prevent them all from leaving
instead of just like waving them goodbye
which is really all that model is
equipped to tell you how to do
um and so like i think that uh this is
the second step should probably be part
of the first step
and it's kind of a sub optimization to
think of them as separate
so i am going to propose and a big
thesis of this of this section of the
talk is that like these two
activities of of business and of society
are sort of like fundamentally
intertwined in a way that
we have underrated and that like you
know thinking about
doing good stuff in the world can inform
how we should be estimating
stuff at the data science phase and so
like when we can tear down this wall we
can actually create like a joint
procedure for doing these things and
that and then this would be a better way
for us to be
for us to be working is like explicitly
acknowledge uh
that we're that we're gonna need to do
these things right
so how do we solve that problem uh well
we add a new variable to the model and
that model contains stuff we can do
about the user
you know potentially turning um and so
we have this like y
y s a s and a are ordered in this way
because this is the order in which they
occur s is sort of like information
that we have available at the time we're
making the prediction and a is a choice
that we make
and then y is what we observe afterward
and this this is sort of like a
ubiquitous
causal architecture for business is like
we have sort of like
collected lots of information we're
forced periodically to make some choices
and then we sort of observe
outcomes that are associated with those
choices and we would like to you know
form some conditional expectation of
what would happen if we took different
kinds of actions this is a this is a
counter factual model
i didn't put any counter factual
language on it judah pearl would really
hate me for not putting a do operator on
the a but like let's just like
we'll get to that in the next section
all right so in this model you are part
of the model
and this is a really underrated aspect
of modeling is i think that like
when we're when we're trained to
scientists we are trained in this uh
very like it's a positivist
regime right it's like that you know the
universe has certain laws and we're
meant to
like learn them and we are passive
observers
of of the of how the universe plays out
and so
even when you write an academic paper
you some people will use like passive
language like the instrument was applied
to whatever and this is explicitly like
you know removing the language of you
being involved in the procedure like you
are you are taken out of the context and
it's sort of like meant to be more
objective
and i think i'm sort of like more on the
other side of like let's just
acknowledge
that that we take a pla we take a part
in the system that we're studying and so
that requires us to like
put variables that represent our own
behaviors and actions like inside the
model
so oh yeah i was just joking around with
like
well the order of the snake could be the
other way we can
make some jokes all right
so we have s and a are our two right
hand side variables
and and then this yields a very useful
kind of visualization which is that what
is the distribution
of state action pairs that we observe in
the data that we have that we have
and so like i call these state action
diagrams but
that yields a very like sad acronym so
we'll call them state action plots
and a very interesting thing about these
pots is that they're not meant to show
the full
joint distribution of of s a
they are meant to show where we have
positivity so this is this is a big
assumption in causal inference is that
we have sort of overlap
um between actions that we would we
would like to predict the outcomes of
actions that we have taken historically
so positivity is sort of like
a necessary condition for us to be able
to infer what would happen
under that particular action given the
state we have to have observed it
historically
in the data we have we have to have the
ability to observe it
and so so these lines the green lines
are showing where we have positive mass
so like where where have we ever done
this action
given this state so this diagram on the
left is very boring one which is that we
always take the same actions like not
give the user a coupon
and so from this model we cannot learn
anything about a world where we gave
them coupons
uh like there's it's just not really in
the in the data for us to say
um and then this diagram over here has
mass in both places which means that
there's a positive probability
given any state of getting a coupon or
not and then in this world for any user
we could tell what would happen if they
got a coupon or not by using by
this is just a pure pure induction we
can we can sort of gather examples of
users that are similar
and when they got a coupon and when they
didn't and then we were able to kind of
like perform this causal inference
problem
um and this this solves the estimation
problem that we have and so these i'll
refer back to these diagrams quite a bit
because they're quite useful
okay so when you're in the model
you fit a model of what happens under
coupon
and no coupon and then you use them and
they suggest
a course of action this is commonly
called a heterogeneous treatment effect
model
where there's sort of like different
effects depending on some context
variable
and so so if we computed some retention
score we might learn like where
the causal effect is the largest so
these are the highest incrementality
people to be giving coupons to so by
fitting the right kind of model rather
than the turn prediction model this
model tells us like what to do like who
to give coupons to
and it also tells us like when the
coupons are actually valuable or not so
there's some people for whom
they're not very useful maybe these
people are gonna leave like anyway
so it doesn't matter if you give them a
coupon or not and so it's sort of like
silly to even even do it and then there
are users where there's very high impact
from giving coupons
so we should give them to those people
even though they look like
um you know they're already like have a
high probability of retaining it's like
the marginal impact
is what matters and so this is a model
that's actionable it translates like the
business problem directly into a course
of action that can be executed like
quite quite readily by ops team whereas
if i handed them like a set of term
production scores they would just take
the top
scorers and just like we would have to
hope that by coincidence those are
also the people with the highest
incrementality
okay story number two forecasting
and i have like some history doing
forecasting uh in my past job and now
currently lift
my team works on forecasting and um
working at lyft has completely changed
the way that i think about forecasting
and i i think you'll you'll see that
sort of baked in here and it's it's
because we have control over the
forecasts and it's very similar to term
predictions like forecasts are just
sort of like status quo forecasts
there's a there's other
other possible counterfactuals so we
have this
normal forecasting model it looks like
this is this our same conditional
expectation function we just changed the
variable definitions so
s is like what we have observed in the
historical data
um and why is like a set of observations
that we will observe in the future
and so we fit models like this all the
time and we evaluate their
forecasting performance and we try to
build ones that forecast things really
well
there's a there's there's like a couple
important things that are missing from
this model
one is the effects of stuff that we did
in the past
so we committed to courses of action
that might have impacts today
and so accounting for the effects of
those pest actions could improve the
model and so by like not
including the things that we have
historically done as
actions and trying to kind of like
anticipate what their effects will be in
the future we have we
have built a broken forecasting model
and then the second thing is stuff that
we can plan to do
to correct the forecast so this is sort
of like you know if the forecast says
things are going to look really bad
we'll clearly do something about it and
then the forecast will be broken
as well because it will sort of not
include the effects of things that we
have chosen to do
in order to you know correct the poor
forecast and try to like you know fix
fix
what we anticipate happening so we have
two kinds of actions that we'd like to
incorporate and we need a causal model
to do this
so here's a good example of the story
that i just told which is like let's say
at lyft we lowered prices
and that happened in the past but people
take some time to respond to price
changes because not everybody uses lift
every day maybe maybe it takes them like
two weeks before their first ride and
they notice
that they see that the list prices are
now lower so we lower prices and then
demand sort of like slowly creeps up
and this relationship is something that
we can estimate from historical data so
we sort of have made price changes in
the past and it's not impossible to
incorporate this information about the
price index
into the future into our into our
forecast
now demand going up means that we might
not have enough drivers
um to meet the demand so we have way
more requests because prices are low
that would be really bad people would be
sort of like waiting a really long time
for rides
and so we'd like to sort of engineer
supply conditions that match the demand
conditions
in some way and we have a tool to do
that which are called driver incentives
where we send offers to drivers
to sort of encourage them to drive more
during times when we have peak demand
and we have to make a plan for how we're
going to set those driver incentives
in advance because drivers need to know
like you know more than just like
right now whether they need to be on the
road to like
to help us like meet all the demand that
we have and so we have the both of these
causes
need to be in the model in order for us
to make effective decisions we sort of
need to know that demand is going to go
up because we lower prices and we need
to know what we can do about it in order
to fix it
so like i need to use a like
models that tell you what will happen
like great but they don't tell you what
to do
then you still have there's still like a
missing step you still have to figure
out like what are you going to do about
it and that's a whole other step that
you have like delegated to someone else
i would say you you've taken a very
narrow view of your job
if you if you sort of like forecast
things and then just leave it to
somebody else to use the forecast and
like figure out what you're supposed to
do about it
and i hate to use a drake meme like in
in 2021
it's just sort of like toying with this
state action notation
and yeah like in 2021 i don't expect you
to be laughing as much about it
okay so we had this causal model
now that the last piece and this is sort
of like you know completes the diagram
of all the stuff that you need to be
an effective data scientist is the art
max operator
so argument acts just says take the best
action
given in the state and find me the best
possible thing that i could do
in this situation and this is this is a
this just like the conditional
expectations operator
is like a beautiful abstraction um arc
max is a great abstraction too which is
sort of like
it's hard to maximize things uh but like
you know assume that we can we're all
we're all smart and we know how to run
lbfgs or
sgd or whatever so we have a model
already we can argmax it we can find the
best plan
and this planning optimal planning
problem is sort of like baked into this
model from the start it is designed to
admit
solutions to the optimal planning
problem and this is what we do at lyft
so we have goals that we'd like to sort
of like achieve and we are making
forecasts that condition on information
about what we will do about it
and the goals are sort of changed the
results of those of the actions change
depending on state
um and so we can kind of like then take
this and build an optimal
planning procedure directly from the
model and
and so this this is sort of like casting
the forecasting problem as a planning
problem
which is exactly what forecasting sort
of like intended to to do if you think
about it
why are we building a forecast is
because we think something's going to
happen in the future that we would like
to respond to
today and use that information in order
to like make take that action and
prevent the bad thing from happening or
make make the good thing happen
okay so that is like act one act two
act three is ranking and recommendations
so so we've done turn prediction we've
done forecasting
and now it's sort of like this is like a
you know content recommendation problem
so picture you're like netflix
and you need to figure out what to
recommend people or or your google and
you're going to put some
search results at the top of the page or
you know pinterest is going to list pins
this is just a ubiquitous data science
problem
um and so like it's also a conditional
expectation function
right so you're you're sort of like even
a recommender system fits into this
framework there's just sort of like
things about
the user and things about the item and
then we you know user clicking on the
item is a pretty bad label here but we
might say like user
like rates the item highly or likes it
or you know
thinks you know watches the whole video
on netflix or something like that would
be
i don't i don't know what outcomes they
use but it sounds like you'd want to you
want to sort of capture something about
like that
that the the recommendation was valuable
to the user as a label
um and so this this seems like a
perfectly plausible
model to fit and it seems like it would
be very useful and in practice people do
ignore
the causal aspect of this model quite a
bit sort of like
that this this data this seems like a
like a reasonable approach to solving
this problem
but everybody who works on recommender
systems knows about position bias
um which is that like we oh sorry
let me get to the position bias in the
next slide i just want to talk about
just briefly
like why we're worried about overlap and
i'm going to get to overlap and
a couple more slides for state action
space
so overlap in the s distribution is
something that we have to think about as
machine learners
so and this this is related to like the
cold start problem and recommender
systems which is like if if there are
s's
that we have never observed in our in
our training sample and we're going to
make a prediction for them it's going to
be a bad
prediction because that model is forced
to extrapolate to a new
a new part of the s space and so what
this is sort of like a you know knowing
the distribution of your training data
and your testing data and your
prediction data and how they differ
is just like a really common problem for
data scientists to encounter and have to
work on and so like when you're working
on non-causal models
we think about this all the time so
we're gonna have to think about
overlapping
in state action space so let's go ahead
and add the action
to the model and if you worked on
recommender systems before you know
about position bias
you know that like you know changing the
position of the item changes the outcome
and so like where you where you
visualize it where you display it to
users will affect whether they attend to
it and whether they're likely to sort of
complete the steps needed
to uh to actually like you know get the
benefits of the recommendation
so if we recommend something really
lonely even if it's a good match like
the outcome might be
might be quite for so we have a role in
generating the data that we don't really
think about
and so like you know one solution to
this is just to gather the position data
while you're while you're training the
model and try to create some adjustment
for it but but actually it is a causal
problem
sort of like we we have we have caused
something to happen
via putting um recommendations in
certain positions
and so the choice of the position is an
action we get to choose we get to choose
a whole slate of positions
so really we're like you know we're
talking about action being sort of a
combinatorial set
of all items and positions that they get
but we'll just abstract that for now and
just say like you know let's just say
like whether it was displayed
to the user or not could be the could be
the position
okay so if we're building a ranking or
recommender system
how are we going to actually run that
model in production
well we're going to score all the items
and so we're going to have this like
score of the based on which is going to
be just a function that we've estimated
from data but it's still
historical so it counts as state and
it's going to be estimated from the data
and we're going to score all the items
and then we're going to a is going to be
the you know how high up
in the ranking or how you know
probability of being seen by the user or
something like that
how it's it's it's an action that we
take
and if we if we built a ranking system
with no exploration
this is what our state action diagram
would look like all the high scores
get high positions all the low scores
get very low positions
and what's the problem with this is that
the low scoring items
we will have never observed them in high
positions
and and the highest scoring items we
will have never observed them in low
positions
and so we have sort of like a missing
data problem we have we have never
observed that action conditional on that
state
and and so that's going to cause us to
to not know
what would have happened in the case
that we so we fill in that model we try
to put in different positions for the
item we're not going to get
um you know the variance of those
estimates is infinite
sort of drawing on zero historical
observations in order to make that
even though most machine learning models
would just spit out a square anyway
um it's it's probably a bad idea to
train a causal model
on data that doesn't actually have any
variation
so how do we solve that problem well we
add exploration to our
to our policy so we and but and
exploration always looks like
more mass in the state action diagram so
here is sort of just like widening this
line into a band is like local
exploration so this is like score
position perturbation we take the you
know we flip a coin and
where we add random noise to the score
and then we re-rank things and then it
sort of like
generates some subtle changes and the
ranking and now we get counter factual
data so we get sort of like state action
pairs that
that we wouldn't have gotten under the
status quo policy
and a very clear implication for this is
that this bears cost
so we are sort of like purposefully
degrading
the quality of our system so that we can
build a better model that can hopefully
yield a better solution in the future so
so
we're sort of like taking a we're paying
a cost to build a better model that will
hopefully benefit us
um but you can see what this is doing is
this is this is turning
this exploration is turning our model
into something that can do a do
operator do operator means that we can
arbitrarily set the value
of a uh with within some with within
some balance
it you know if we want a model that we
can put in do
a then we need to actually have done
that thing in the past and historical
data
and so in a pure explorer regime is sort
of like you know it's madness because
you're
every item has a problem as a positive
probability of being in any
any position um which would probably
look like a really bad recommender but
it would be really easy
to to model that causally because you'd
have positive support
for any action given any state
so what does overlap protein
distributions look like in state action
space
well now we have to like use little
rectangles and
i hate these diagrams could look like a
flag of a country that i can't name
um and so like the way to think about
this is like we have collect data
collection policy which is data we've
you know we've gathered to produce our
model then we have target policy which
is like policy we'd like to be able to
estimate
what will happen this task is often
called off policy evaluation
so if we've gathered data under the
yellow policy
we have no ability to estimate what
would happen under the blue policy
here because because we've never
observed those actions in the states
it's very similar to the yes coupon no
coupon
version of the world so taking more
actions always yields like
you know like expanding the set of
actions that you take always yields
a better you know better set of data
because it sort of you know can answer
more questions about more different
actions that you could have taken
we can produce uh you know cases of
partial overlap where we can say
something but there are some kind of
actions that we can't say anything about
and so there's you know there's models
like this where like we're able to
extrapolate a little bit but not all the
way
and then in a full overlap situation we
have like gathered data in this like
expansive way
and then um we're able to kind of any
any like
data any target policy that's contained
within the set
of positive uh pos you know positive
state action pairs
is sort of like something that we can
get an unbiased estimate for
so this is a this is sort of like in a
way that
the causal inference is on easy mode but
it is a
it is an important causal reference
problem is that we like in in the case
where we have full overlap we still need
to figure out how to reweight the data
that we have in order to kind of mimic
the target distribution that we that we
want and so
when i talk about causal inference here
i'm talking about like full of fully
observable confounding
and so it is a solvable problem and it's
solvable through normal causal inference
techniques it just happens to be ones
where we like have really good answers
to the questions about
how much bias is going to be introduced
by that particular technique which which
if we do the weighting rate will be zero
okay so we've done term prediction
we've done forecasting we've done
ranking and recommendations
i've sort of i think i hope i made the
case that they're all like
causal models and and that they if
they're made puzzle models we sort of
have made explicit an assumption
that we have made like that we haven't
made or we've sort of expanded the model
to be able to answer
more questions and more interesting and
actionable questions
than they could before and and that's a
good thing and it means that like
you know that we have been able to uh
put ourselves in the model
and make the models do things that we
naturally need to do
as data scientists rather than just
train something and like blindly get
a prediction out of it so let's try to
like synthesize
what we've what we've learned into like
more of a coherent framework
so fundamentally what i'm trying to what
i'm trying to propose here
is that um on the left-hand side we have
the machine learner's perspective
which is i can just like fit a model
with state action pairs
and outcomes and and i'll just use that
model
and that's fine and that's the case
where i don't need causal inference
because i can just use
whatever conditional expectation
function that i want
and then on the right hand side i have
causal inference which is like i have to
estimate
this function with the do operator which
means i need overlap
and i need to choose some weighting
algorithm in order to in order to adjust
for the difference in the sampling
between my training data and the test
data so just being
aware of the state action distributions
and then and then correcting for it for
the target distribution that i have i
have in mind
so when when are these two things equal
is when you don't need causal inference
if they're equal then the machine
learner and the causal influence person
get the exact same answer to the
question and so causal inference was
like a total waste of time for us
so so really we want to know is like
when they're not equal that's when you
need causal inference
you can derive from from everything that
i just talked about the two the two
conditions
under which uh this thing is trivially
true so it's it's true
either if you have no actions at all so
actions the action set
is is null set and so we we sort of like
don't have any actions to take
and that's that's a world where you
can't do anything but it's also a world
where you don't need causal imprints
because those models are trivially the
same
so if you have no variables that you
have any control over then you don't
need causal inference
but i would argue that so that probably
never happens
and then on the right hand side here we
have the no confounding uh condition so
if there's no confounding then then it's
fine that means that
a is just a is independent of uh
of s like they're completely you know
completely independent variables
then yeah you can just put them in the
same model and you get like a reasonable
answer
to the to the question of like what will
happen if you do a
um and and this is true for like
you know some design data that we might
create like experiments and stuff like
that
but it's not true if we used the state
to select a
which is extremely common it was like in
what world would you take actions
and not use some of the state
information
to choose the action that would be kind
of crazy
and so like so here's the the diagram of
like when you know when you need causal
inference so
on the on the x-axis i have control
which is the size of the set
of the actions that you can take and we
can even operationalize control in a
more precise
way which is like you know the total
effects that we could generate
from the set of actions that we have
available how much power do we have
as people operating within the system do
we have the power to make anything
happen is really the question that we
have and then on the y-axis i have like
amount of confounding and here it's like
fixable
confounding through causal inference
methods but when we have when we have
confounding we need to use
something that looks like causal
inference methods to correct for the way
that the sample
that we've gathered is different from
the sample that we would like to
estimate
which which is sort of like that do
operator
so so what happens here in the and the
control is very low
there's nothing to do so i'm going to
argue if you don't have anything to do
then it's not really you know it's not a
valid case
then in the case where we have zero
confounding is just we just ran like a
pure randomized experiment so
we could argue whether you should do
that or whether you should just skip to
this like contextual policy optimization
uh or maybe we can just count randomized
experiments as causal improvements to
begin with but either way this is the
this is the realm of where you need
causal inferences if you're going to do
anything
and you're going to use the state in
order to choose the choose what you do
then you need causal inference and i
think that that's mostly all the time
all right that's the that's the the end
of
the always argument
cool how am i doing on time
all right section number two we never
need causal inference
this is gonna be like you know actually
more more challenging for me to do
because i think i was
more previously more aligned with the
first one so i'm gonna
i'm gonna like kind of uh first
draw the dag you haven't seen a single
tag in any of this so far so i purposely
kind of like kept out all the dags
that was and that was on purpose and
like there's this like fun meme on
twitter which is like
draw the dag where you tell people to
draw dags of things that don't make a
lot of sense
um but it is very useful to take like
what i was just showing you and draw
dags of it
it's just sort of like dags are useful
and they're great tool
and i i think that everybody everybody
should learn them but let's let's go and
drop dags for like what we what we were
just doing
um so the three dags on the top
are are very reasonable data generating
processes that you might encounter in
practice under the model
that i that i just described or sort of
like we can condition on two variables
like you know state and action and then
we can generate some
outcome as a result of the action that
we take so
randomized experiment is where we just
don't even have condition and state and
we just sort of like
actions are chosen randomly and they
affect the outcome
so don't need causal importance for this
this is a stupid dag because it's very
boring
it's just it's just saying sort of like
we did something and we observe the
outcome and we can just like
take difference in means to compute
effects
and the second one there's no
confounding because
s a is chosen independently of s so this
is also
quite a boring setup the s is just
providing like variance reduction for
the effect of a on
why and sort of like maybe you can you
know compute use a
heterogeneous treatment effects model
here or something like that so
but it's you know there's no confounding
so you can use machine learning will get
you a reasonable answer here as well
and then on the right we have like the
case where we observe the
confounders and use them to choose a
because we operate
the system that chooses a
and so we do need the do operator here
but but this tag is also quite boring
right it just says that there's
confounding but we can fix it is what
the dag tells you um
it's like you know a is confounded by s
but we can condition on s and block the
backdoor path
and so there's really no identification
problem at all so so these are all
special dags where a is a parent
node pure parent node except for in
cases where it isn't
it has a parent that we can that we also
know about right so we know the
treatment assignment mechanism perfectly
and when we know the treatment
assignment mechanism we essentially know
the distribution of p
p of a given s which which is which is
this arrow here
we don't need any fancy causal inference
tools
to to to apply to these dags they're all
sort of like solvable with like pretty
standard statistical
techniques so the dags themselves are
sort of like stories but they're not
very
interesting stories and they don't tell
us much about what we should do they
actually
actually sort of like end at a point
where the interesting part just gets
started which is like how do we analyze
the data
that we generated under a dag that was
created like this
now if we have a confounded dag which is
like you know all observational data has
this like potential that there was a
variable that you didn't observe that
affected what action was taken
and this is super common in the social
scientists like you know humans take
actions based on information that they
have that we can't get out of their
heads
and and so we just don't know this u and
we don't know what the set u
is and so we don't know what to
condition on to block the backdoor path
and d bias the estimate of the effect of
a on y
so what do we know if we know we don't
control the
the treatment assignment mechanism it
means that we don't know
how the action was chosen it means that
the confounding
could be arbitrary we can get an
arbitrarily wrong answer here i mean
sure there's lots of work on sort of
bounding how wrong we could be but
but it is a sort of a case where we
don't control it
we couldn't have controlled it we don't
know how it was set and and
if we try to analyze the data we're
going to get it we're going to get a
wrong answer
so the answer is the question is like
when should you use observational data
to take actions i i would argue like
potentially the answer is never
um because we should just use
experiments and try to like stick to the
dags on the top and solve the kinds of
problems that we can get good answers to
now this is a super strong perspective
and i think i don't even fully believe
it but
let's let's talk more we'll get some
more about like you know what
what what role the dags are playing and
why we might think about compounding but
i think one one reasonable story is that
i'm going to use
the understanding that i get from this
to like suggest
an action that i will test using one of
the top tags later
but but i sort of like you know that's a
that's a reasonable argument is that
i can like generate some knowledge that
a human can then use to go design an
experiment that might actually
give us a well identified estimate
so people who like dags love to talk
about mechanisms because
you know it's one of the great things
that they can kind of help provide
answers to
so so in the case here we might say hey
like a caused y and we got a really
clean
estimate of that from our great
experiment that we ran but did it cause
y
via mechanism m1 or m2 and that would
matter because
i've got this other treatment that's
laying around and
it operates through mechanism m1 or m2 i
have action a1 and a2
and i'm going to decide like which of
those two things to work on you can
think of these like you know
maybe like ads like you know this was
this was a super effective ad did it
appeal to
you know their sense of belonging in our
community or did it appeal to their need
for technical features
if it was like the other the latter then
you would want to sort of like develop
an ad that was different
um so it's it's super plausible that you
you would
want to use your knowledge of the effect
on the mechanism
to to kind of like generate a new action
from intuitions so maybe
maybe like dags are useful at least in
the case where we want to do that
so we can tell like there's a little
interesting story and i highly recommend
reading the article it's
it's super super interesting like
epistemologically
it's like the and it's it's become a
parable at this point but
there is a really interesting story
about it the lost cure for scurvy
and and so scurvy is like a disease that
you get when
you're on ship for a long time and you
don't have access to vitamin c
we know this now because we have great
research and have done a lot of science
on it
and people go on these long journeys and
not have access to fresh fruits and
vegetables
get scurvy and has terrible symptoms by
all accounts of horrible disease
and you know they learn that consuming
lemon juice
cured scurvy like could basically
prevent anybody from ever getting it
and you could like it could be operating
through like
either vitamin c levels or like you know
maybe just delicious
citrus fruits are the kind of thing that
cure scurvy and some other
mechanism that we don't know about so so
a bunch of british sailors go on a trip
and they they take lime juice because
lime limes are just like lemons right
and then they put them in copper tanks
exposed to the air and it like you know
uh
destroys all the vitamin c in the juice
and so
this lime juice like tastes like juice
like and it tastes like what they were
taking before but it doesn't have
vitamin c anymore and so it doesn't
operate on the same mechanism
and it doesn't it doesn't cure scurvy
anymore i should have just removed this
arrow from the diagram
so that you know that doesn't work you
know you can't
you can't use that treatment and so if
we if they knew this mechanism was
important and they knew
that lemon and lemon juice had vitamin c
and lime juice didn't
then this is valuable knowledge right
you would you would know that this like
this what this thing wasn't going to
help you
on your on your trip at all
but like you know i'm going to take the
experimentalist perspective here and say
like okay like we could have just lime
juice is just the new action
right and so you just assumed you had no
positivity when you just put people on a
ship with lime juice
and said you know it's going to be good
just try it out
and you never tried it before that would
be a bad idea right like you're kind of
like trying a new action without
any any inferential ability to say what
will happen there
so the experimentalists would get this
problem right too right like you know if
i
if i were just sort of like testing new
cures for scurvy and i were i had a good
experimental design
knowledge i i wouldn't i wouldn't try to
just like
cure scurvy without experimenting on it
first with with you know with some kind
of like
positivity in that part of the
distribution where we tried lime juice
in estimating this outcome um and
fun fact like the isolation of vitamin c
wasn't until 19
1932 so we didn't even know what vitamin
c was until like 200 years
after this anecdote or sorry the
anecdote is like 1911. so it's like 20
years too late
they knew what um they knew what vitamin
c was
so even if even if like you had to wait
even to understand what the mechanism
was we had to identify and measure the
mechanism these are all cases where like
you could still get the right answer
without knowing this by running
experiments or you wait until
do all this costly research and find out
what vitamin c is and als also that
humans
just like can understand like why it
worked but you could
you could have just gotten the right
answer and had something that worked
like without
doing any of that science stuff and
having humans been in the loop in any
way so
just kind of like interesting thought
experiment there
so the the big claim of this section is
that like those dags that have
action as the parent node that i control
is just experimentation
it's where i get to like take
interventions myself and shoot you know
choose the value of certain variables in
the system
experimentation is a proven architecture
for accumulating
use useful causal knowledge now it
doesn't mean that it tells us like why
things happen
but it does tell us like what will
happen if we do certain things which is
sort of like
maybe the most important thing that we
can do in a practical setting
so if we're looking for a useful causal
knowledge then i would argue
experimentation
sort of obviates the need for dags and
that
in many cases the dag is just sort of
like a story that you tell
uh after the fact but the experiment was
the thing that really gave you the
answer in the first place the dag didn't
give you the answer
so this is this is a relatively strong
perspective but if you have the ability
to experiment
um which which i hope that you do if
you're doing things that you
if you have control over the system
anyway then then adding randomness to
that is a very natural next step
and then then you're in a world where
the dags are not super useful anymore
so this is my like you know bear bear
case for
causal inference
but i will say that actions have to come
from somewhere
so we put like coupons coupons came from
you have a theory
in your head that like people like
discounts and so there was like like a
note in the graph
that you had in your head which is like
um the
like the cheapness of the product and
you and you had this idea that cheapness
of the product was going to like
cause people to be less likely to turn
turn from your product
um and that's a human intuition
and so maybe maybe like human design is
sort of where actions come from
and that's a very reasonable role for
causal inferences that if you have a dag
in your head and it may suggest sort of
like things that you want to
you want to apply as treatments and then
we will go run an experiment on that but
that
but you're still using a dag and causal
inference as like a
you know hypothesis generation engine i
can get behind that and i think that
that's relatively reasonable
this is the most important when the
feedback loop is really slow so
why do we need human design it's because
humans have good priors they're bringing
a lot more information to the table than
a model that have available
and so yeah like by all means you know
humans design experiments that's that's
what we do we sort of like pick new
product directions we pick
we pick designs um we we choose like
whole bundles of things as actions
rather than just like a b
before the a and the b test is actually
like a super well designed and
engineered
thing that we're comparing against one
another and so that's a slow feedback
loop and say sure we need human design
and humans need to solve some
sort of like speculative causal
inference problem in order to in order
to do that
but there is a world where he where
machines can design the action space
and that's very reasonable as well and
humans have a role here too which is to
create a hypothesis space
for machines to explore um and this can
be this can be many things that don't
you know come to mind very easily like a
whole app or website can be
parameterized into like how big are
buttons and what color are they
and what position are they in or you
know text or movies can be parameterized
in various ways like star you know stars
tom cruise or star someone who looks
like tom cruise are like factors about a
movie so you can design a movie
parametrically
um if you wanted to and and then you
know then it's just about how fast can
you test it and get feedback about
whether that set of parameters
corresponds to like a successful outcome
and in a case where you have a feedback
loop that's fast then i think i would
argue
that machine exploration of action space
is probably in general
and machines generating new actions is
probably a much more efficient way to do
it because
they'll be able to kind of generate
candidates more effectively so if you
have a well parameterized space
and you can get fast feedback then then
we don't need humans to design actions
anymore and so like
this is the world where like you know ai
can can automatically generate actions
and automatically test which ones are
good
and so like you know humans don't really
have a great role anymore in that one
um we can talk about that's a good thing
or not
okay that's a good segue into like
i just i just articulated like a causal
architecture that actually sounds kind
of terrifying right it's like you know
we've given machines sort of like
actions that they can take and we're
like trusting this like
you know these systems to to operate
safely
so you know maybe we haven't learned
anything like if we if we give systems
the ability
like ai to the ability to reason about
causality then it can do things like
this
like like articulate that oh this is why
my
robot uprising failed and then like i'll
send a terminator
back in time to uh prevent that from
happening
and then you know there's lots of
additional consequences from that
like kyle reese comes back and makes
sure the terminator doesn't kill sarah
connor and then
then it's kind of become self-aware
because of that and
all right this is this is all nonsense
um
actually this is the problem it's not
robot uprising
it's this it's we are going to apply
this maximization operator and
maximizations are kind of terrifying if
you think about them because they're
sort of like
they're going to find everything that's
wrong in your model so if you maximize
something
then you better gamble be sure that
you're maximizing the right thing
and it's optimization technology is
really probably the scariest piece to
this because it's sort of like it's hope
climbing and
you have to have chosen the hill
correctly and i made this argument quite
a few times
about metrics like choosing metrics and
whether you're optimizing the right
thing
i do think it's like a relatively
ill-considered
aspect of data science and it follows
naturally from that
data science you know pathway that i was
i was showing you in the first couple
slides
which is that you start with i need to
make something good happen
but like the very next step is i need
this to not do something bad
it's like because making something good
happen might have some consequence that
we didn't anticipate
so controlling and managing risk of
models that act
in the real world is is a really
important part of the
part of the process and then naturally
if you have bad things and good things
like both of those things are going to
happen sometimes and so you're going to
need to actually manage trade-offs and
so
you know you need to get if you if you
live in a world where
you're going to use algorithmic decision
making then it strongly implies that
managing trade-offs is
like first-order concern for you because
maximization needs to
sort of have something to kind of pull
it back from over-exploiting
and then very naturally sort of like
someone's got to help you
you have to come to a consensus as an
organization or as a society
about where you should be on the on the
trade-off curve
and and so this this is the path that
we're seeing play out
and we're going to see more of it
because we're building systems that like
can
can act and do things in the real world
and so like they're they're going to be
based on causal models they're going to
be able to optimize these are all like
known
working technologies and and we're
really going to need to start thinking
really carefully about
these next couple boxes so you know you
started the journey
the very beginning of this talk of like
should i choose python or r
and the end of the journey is like am i
going to like enact this
the collapse of society through you know
creating a model and some optimization
and some action space
that that can do that kind of thing and
i i do think that that's the kind of
responsibility that you should be
thinking about first
uh and all the whole way along
okay so what have we emitted from the
model and why why is trust
and trust and response why is safety and
responsibility so hard it's because
the model is misspecified um the actions
perfectly well specified
we we know those because we control them
the state space
you know we could be missing features
that's sort of like a well-known problem
but the y variable we have not talked
about at all
she's like what is why where where did
we get it like is it the right
is it the right thing to be optimizing
for or estimating in the first place
and and to be honest with you i don't
know many people that think really hard
about the why's in their models it you
know it's it's sort of like common to
use the thing that's conveniently
available
and it's also common to just use one
thing um
and and sort of like forget about
trade-offs and so
what i would push you to do if you're
thinking about safety and responsibility
it's all about what you put into that y
variable and how many
how many things you consider and whether
they represent the needs and risks to
your
to your stakeholders and so you can kind
of picture how this plays out is if we
if we sort of only measure one thing in
y and it's a good thing
then we're going to maximize the hell
out of it and we're going to end up here
and if there's a trade-off between
y1 and y2 we get we end up at this point
and so this this curve are all sort of
states of the world that we can operate
in so we can we can choose from among
these possibilities these are all like
this is called a
production possibilities frontier and
economics like we're able to like choose
a point on this curve and
and get what we want we have to choose
it and that's sort of like an important
question
for for any business or society or
organization it's like
where do we want to operate how much of
this bad thing are we going to tolerate
and for whom
or will we will we tolerate it maybe
maybe the value of this changes
depending on the state
as well all right
so just to sort of slowly wrap up here
um i hope i've convinced you causal
inference is useful
in a lot of settings if you define it a
certain way and also sort of like maybe
maybe some of it's a little overblown
like maybe you don't need
like all the all the fancy causal
inference stuff all the time because
there's there's ways to structure
your problems and your data collection
and the way that you operate that so
that
you you make the problem easier and you
don't need kind of all the fancy
machinery that causal inference can
provide you and and that's just sort of
like a standard story that tools
tools are just tools and they're useful
in certain settings and not useful in
others and so
there's nothing really super surprising
about the fact that you might sometimes
need causal inference and sometimes you
don't but but it's the it's the
consistency part that i think you need
to
just like you know you know not to
always use the same modeling technique
because there are some that might work
better
you know you shouldn't be just as
consistent about you know applying
causal inference strictly all the time
when you don't need it or
we're not applying it all the time
because you just don't think that you
need it
and i i read this this quote was really
good
in that it actually sort of has this leg
with consistency
a great soul has simply nothing to do
um but you can invert this the other way
as like having nothing to do
and no action space yields a great
amount of consistency
for for you as a person so like it's
actually quite
easy to simplify and make a really
consistent career as a data scientist if
you just don't do anything
um but i would argue that it's really
hard to have
like a productive and successful career
if you don't think about the
consequences
of that simple conditional expectations
function that you're
that you're working all the time to make
good
so just to conclude
i'm claiming you can do most of data
science with three variables now we can
make them tensor valued or
you know very high dimensional or
whatever but it's really ought to be
enough for
most business problems which is like we
observe a state stuff we know
stuff we can do stuff that happens like
that's that's a fundamental
architecture um if we are careful
to design the data generating process
correctly where we where we
explore actions based on states then we
only really need very straightforward
causal inference to learn everything
that we need to know like we don't need
anything fancy
at all i mean some of the modeling
techniques are fancy and interesting and
they have their own sort of
interestingness but we we don't really
need like
dags or super complicated identification
arguments in this setting
sort of work are capable of engineering
a system that
that can answer questions with
relatively routine statistical
analysis and dags are useful tools but
they're more useful for humans like
they're useful for us to tell stories
and to help us determine um like
what things might be happening in a
system and for us to reason about things
uh but but they're sort of like you know
in in this particular regime which is a
which is a very flexible and it covers a
very broad array of data science
problems
um they they sort of like we can mostly
omit them and get away with not thinking
about them
and just to kind of like i i i refuse to
do anything super technical in this talk
but i'm going to provide all the
pointers that you need if you're if you
want to know more
about everything that i talked about
there's so many different topics that i
touched on that like that
like every little detail like how do we
estimate the conditional expectation
function
with with causal interpretation is a
super interesting problem
how do we sample actions given states
and how do we do that adaptively
is a super interesting set of problems
how do we
like perform this maximization problem
and one of the things we've been doing
on my team is using differentiable
programming to make models that are easy
to
optimize and that's been like super
super fun and interesting to see how
that plays out
but also like you know that art max
requires you know
designing metrics and estimating
trade-offs and eliciting
preferences from users so just like a
ton of interesting
questions in there and research topics
and then like i didn't talk about
variants like one time
in this whole talk which is like you
know maybe you also care about the
variance of that estimate and like
whether
you're likely to be right in this sort
of like in a risk management
setting that wouldn't be really first
order um that you care about sort of
like minimizing some downside risk or
you care about like this is uh this is
like
very bayesian and i didn't talk about
any uncertainty or
you know even even gathering sample size
at all here
but it's it's a super interesting
problem of like how would you estimate
how wrong you're likely to be
in that conditional expectation function
so so these four topics like fundamental
to
this like nascent field of like what i'm
calling causal engineering
um and there's plenty of pointers there
and i'm happy to happy to provide more
so with that i'll stop and take some
questions
so thank you very much that was terrific
i'm going to give you a golf clap and i
hope everyone else in the chat can do it
also
um we miss the times where people get a
nice big applause
from the crowd is always great in person
this would have gotten a huge applause
if we were in person so
please accept my verbal applause as a
big crowd of cheering for you
we had we had a
some questions come in but feel free to
ask more questions folks as i ask the
questions and sean
answers uh please feel free to chime in
if something um i think that was ken but
i'm not sure just that
excellent presentation not a question
but still nice to hear ken thank you
excellent presentation great slides um
speaking of your slides that uh vc focus
slide
was really great um i really appreciated
that one
and i will be i already tweeted a photo
of it so i need to actually tweet an
actual
real still of it um that was just i just
posted the link to the slides in the um
in the in the chat too you can share
this like i'm not on the sucker
yep i'll share this in slack and then
we'll also we'll be posting the actual
slides and the video
up at nyhackr.org um hopefully for the
next few days
we'll have that up there so everyone
just check out nyhackguard.org
there's a very crappily written page
presentations
page up there you can actually search
for sean's name you'll see this talk in
his previous talks
um and by the way if anyone wants to
redesign that is open source it's on
github at github.com
please redesign it it was built pre-hugo
pre-blog down of straight up regular
markdown
please redesign it i i i can't stress
that enough because
i designed it and you see my aesthetic
for there it just wasn't working
so i really want someone to redesign my
personal website so anybody who wants to
help me with that
is it available publicly on github and
then it's on github yeah yeah
they can make a pr for you too that's
perfect
all right so we had a few things come in
and let me just i saw one come in i need
to okay great
um here's a question for early on and
you did touch upon it later but you know
that was a good question
um am i wrong in thinking that the last
slide i don't have the reference for you
but the reference hopefully the question
will give you context
am i wrong in thinking that the last
slide for similarities to beijing
optimization
except now we're trying to build an
active causal learning algorithm that
can determine the optimal sequence of
interventions
yes yeah a lot of this is inspired by
things like banded algorithms and
contextual bandits and bayesian
optimization
and you know like one of the things i
didn't touch on at all was like how
how often do you change the p
probability of a given s
and so banded algorithms change that as
the data streams in so i would call that
like an online
learning algorithm but you can do you
can do these learning things in batch so
you can just like wait a month
and then re you know change the
distribution and then so
so it's a little bit a little bit tied
in with bandit architecture but it
doesn't need to be
so these things can be you can run
sequences of experiments and that can
approximate what uh what a bandit does
and bayesian optimization is just sort
of like bandits for continuous variables
one way to think about it bandits tend
to be sort of focused on discrete
discrete action sets but in many cases
you have continuous ones
and if you want to learn more about
bandits uh go to that
aforementioned poorly designed webpage
and
search for shane conway and john miles
white
they both given bandits talks and so is
emily robinson her talk wasn't
necessarily about bandits but it was
about bandits
and those are the three that come to the
top of my mind
and i know i like to particularly
mention shane and john because they are
members back when uh back when sean was
living in new york with us
big big fan of both of them they're
pretty awesome
um you mentioned about judea pearl be
mad at you for not using the do notation
can you get more into that like why is
such an important thing to have the do
notation
yeah i mean um today pearl's a really
smart guy and has done a lot of great
work you know
it's very i found it really
inspirational to borrow ideas
from from his work and um the do
operator is important it's sort of like
it is important to specify
like what can be estimated from the data
you know
and the do operator fundamentally tells
you like
like that it is a different thing you're
estimating when you want to set the
value of a variable than when you want
to condition on it
and and you know setting means it can be
set to any arbitrary
value um given given s and that's
different than like
you know just whatever value nature gave
you for that thing it's a fundamentally
more useful
useful thing to know um i think he takes
a pretty
strong view that like not not putting a
do operator in from the start
means that you are
you you are doomed to never be able to
solve the hardest problems
of causal inferences so like would you
appreciate this talk you would say you
always need
my causal inference because i i will
show you
cause inference problems that you can't
solve using
uh you know using anything but what i
have design
and i i think my argument is something
like actually there's a simplified set
of data science problems where you
really don't
don't need all of that machinery and
it's much simpler than that and so like
so if you want to solve all these hard
problems sure like yes i have not
encountered those problems personally as
a
data scientist so uh so like so that's
why i think he might
be a little mad about this but you know
i'm a big i'm a big fan of his i do
get into arguments with him on twitter
but i think everybody does
yeah and he and he's open and engaging
about it too
yeah we would love to have him speak one
time here um
shane's not at nyu and he didn't want
you a long time ago we'll try to find
some way to get him involved
um speaking of judea pearl i'm gonna
give you a leading one um some of the
best books you've seen for uh learning
causal inference
yeah that's a really good question um
so i i think that there are some good
ones that sort of are focused on the
scientific
application of causal inference uh so so
you know there's uh calls inference
mixtape scott scott cunningham
is a more recent one and um mostly
harmless econometrics is quite a good
one for economists also
uh you know pearl's book pearls book of
why or
and they all give you very different
perspectives on it and i think that a
lot a lot of ways this talk is a
response to the fact that i
have not seen good materials about like
how to apply these techniques in
practice like they
often sort of teach you like little
parables like you know
smoking causes cancer and so you learn
these little stories but they don't tell
you like how am i gonna use this in my
job
how am i going to get something done and
i do think that we're missing a little
bit of
effort there and that the causal causal
influence of machine learning
intersection is just starting to take
place some people would argue it's been
taking place for a long time but i would
argue practical tools are just
starting to emerge there um and so i i
can't point to any specific resource
there
there are there are some really good
researchers out there that are kind of
at the forefront of this i think
um one of my favorites is nathan kalas
who's a
researcher at kernel tech um and
you know doing really good work and some
of the key words you might look for
there like
off policy evaluation is really
important contextual bandwidth
optimization
also sort of fundamental to this and
basically optimization and also
fundamental um
it's on bakshi's group that facebook is
he's a good friend
and they do awesome research you can go
to like acts.dev and find out a lot
about
adaptive experimentation which is really
sort of like a
an engineering approach to what i just
described
and um sean is just learning that he'll
be giving a how-to of code in a few
months at a future meetups
let's choose his favorite language and
it teaches all yep
um how do you
uh and folks if you need those resources
maybe sean you could just uh tell us
later that you know
some of those books that you know you
mentioned mixtape you know there's a
recording
cousin friends mixtape the question of
book of why ask.dev and facebook and
you might have mentioned one thing you
want me to sing a lot i'll write it down
cool thanks thank you because i know
this would be very popular afterwards
um let me see oh here's like sort of a
follow-up question that you i'm gonna
give it to you anyway just because um
you sort of already answered it is there
an accessible reference paper
or open source code for applying causal
inference to a forecasting problem
specifically
yeah that's a much harder question
right so causal ideas
and forecasting is actually has a
historical precedent that goes back
quite a long ways to
macroeconomic forecasters i used to work
at the federal reserve board and that's
sort of like a first order question is
like what should we set the interest
rate to
to make sure that the economy grows fast
but not too fast
and and that's so putting themselves in
the model was sort of like very early in
in macroeconomic forecasting
especially for central banks i don't
have any papers at hand that i can i can
point to
and in fact like i think most of their
there's a lot of great ideas to borrow
there but i don't know how particularly
practical they are
because macroeconomic forecasting has to
face this sort of like uh
they worry about the people in the model
optimizing in
in response to their decisions so it's a
game theoretic problem you have to sort
of solve for an equilibrium
and so it's a little a little different
in nature than things where we can
assume that people aren't
smart enough to optimize in response to
what you're going to do
um so i we have we have we have coded up
most of our stuff in pi torch and have
built
for forecasting models that have causal
components one one of the kind of key
concepts there is what's what we call
causal
causal convolution so convolutional
neural network is really great for
two-dimensional images right sort of
like moves a little window across the
image
you also have a 1d convolution which is
like a sliding window across
an input wave and so on you can think of
your policies as input waves and
compilations as the effects of those
waves and that's an idea that we've used
and gotten a lot of leverage out of um
i don't have like i don't have any
resources we built a bunch of stuff but
it's sort of like all in-house um
i hope we get to write some blog posts
about it someday soon
so it would go beyond like putting an
exogenous variable and something like
profit for instance
yeah profit profit cannot do this and so
i haven't yeah
if only you someone could fix that yeah
well i think it should be something new
i think
um profit said profits close to
future feature complete so well maybe
there'll be a new package someday that
can do that
you got to come up with like a profit in
another language that way you know
some other language um all right
wait no i want to that's just what ask
that one um how do you distinguish
between
confounders and prognostic variables
yeah that's a good question so so
prognostic variables are predictive of
the outcome
um and so they can be used mostly for
what's called variance reduction which
is like you know you're explaining more
of
the reason for the outcome from from the
s's so then it allows the
variation that's due to the actions that
you take to be to be
easier to easier to see
and confounders are variables that are
are like kind of like
also having an effect on the on the
action itself and really the reality is
a lot of variables are kind of like both
because if you're if you're using these
the actions to choose what to do
and they have some influence on the um
on the outcome then
they're probably a little bit of both
now knowing if it's a confounder is like
is your business right so if you i would
this is a strong perspective but if
you're taking an action in your business
and you don't know what contributed to
it and you're not blogging
it then you're sort of like making a
fundamental mistake that's going to
prevent you from learning in the future
so people call this exposure logging or
but like you know building a good
logging system that captures like the
why that you took
actions and if there's a randomness in
it which there should be then you need
to have logged that as well
um so yeah the answer is like whether
it's prognostic or not is estimatable
from the data whether it's a confounder
or not is something that you have to
know
from with domain knowledge and have sort
of either like engineered or
assumed great
and i guess sort of about knowing
um things there's a question about
a lot of job postings right now focusing
on languages and packages and ml models
do you think they'll be more of a push
toward having these calls and print
skills in the future
in the near future or do you think it's
gonna be more just about you know
implementing
yeah it's a good that's another good
question i mean i think that so on the
one hand we're really lacking people and
causal influence skills
um in industry and it's very hard to
hire for
finding people with prior experience is
challenging so i i would encourage
everybody to learn about it and get
experience because it will make you more
marketable
i would like to hire you if you're
really good i know a lot about causal
imprints so i hope
i hope people are willing to take that
on faith um i do think that some of this
stuff
is gonna turn into the realm of
engineering in the future just like it's
the same arc for a lot of machine
learning systems is like you know
do we really need humans building models
eventually
hyper parameter tuning is is automated
and feature engineering is automated and
i think some of the causal inference
stuff will sort of tend toward
engineering systems in the future and so
the role of data science and causal
imprints will become a little bit less
but there we're much earlier in that
cycle for causal inference where there's
still a lot of human
domain knowledge that's needed to solve
these problems in practice and
much less automatable because there's a
lot of like assumptions that are needed
by humans in order to
make these things work and the modeling
architectures are just more complicated
when you're jointly modeling actions and
states you need to treat the actions
differently i i abstracted this
completely in the
in the talk but actions are
fundamentally different kinds of
variables and need to be
fit differently than just like standard
features in the machine learning model
it's very inefficient to fit them
you know just as like other kinds of
features there's a large literature on
that
and knowing how to do that is very
useful because you get a lot
more precise information about what's
likely to happen under
certain kinds of actions so i think it's
a really deep area to learn it's very
useful to learn it's probably going to
be a great
job skill at a lot of places all
marketplace companies
like uh you know any place that sort of
like
operates a marketplace is very concerned
about causal influence because they care
a lot about like what they can do to
cause the marketplace to function more
efficiently but um
uh it's it's not going away and there's
going to be a lot of jobs i'm pretty
sure
and uh speaking of jobs someone just
wrote in a little bit
a little bit ago how did you personally
decide between academia and industry
oh i like uh didn't get sleep for like
three months of my life and
was a miserable wreck uh no i i had a i
had a really good experience
interning at facebook when i was in grad
school and i i was like i was in new
york at the time
and i i came up to california and um i i
felt like in industry i was learning
very quickly because i was exposed to
this constant stream of
problems so you know being a consultant
internally at facebook working on what
you know what was coming up there
was a little bit of a preview of the
future you know you were seeing the
kinds of problems that companies were
going to have
like you know way before the industry
right before the academic researchers
were thinking about them so i always
felt like um i was learning so much
faster there that like i would choose
a job where i learned quickly more than
a job where i wasn't learning very
quickly and i had kind of tapped out on
what i could learn from reading papers
and being in seminars and stuff like
that
uh i still miss my academic life and i
do miss
sitting down and writing papers and it's
pretty tough to get that anywhere else
and if
you really do like having open-ended
research problems and a lot of space and
bandwidth to work on them and it's
pretty hard to replicate that in
industry so
so you can't it's not just a free lunch
but um
but it was a tough decision and there's
there's the world where i'm
like a professor struggling to get
tenure right now that i'm like a little
bit
terrified of so
no looking back with regrets no no
that's a question i've asked of you
before in the past i'm glad someone else
asked you again
yeah um and calling back is something
you actually mentioned when you talked
about the when you worked at the fed
um does causal inference have any
difficulty incorporating
deliberately adversarial behavior into
the model how do you account for that
yeah it's uh because it's a really good
question um
you know typically we're at the we're in
the world where we don't think about
that
too much because so okay here's a good
example like lift
lift coupons right so we like we give
out coupons we use a model to do that
um and you might think like oh i could
figure out like what
the algorithm is and like you know do
the kind of behaviors that cause
to give me coupons we should be we
should be worried about that and that's
that's the thing that like you know you
know gaming the system so that you you
produce the kind of features that get
you benefits
um and there is some literature on that
no um
this name is escaping me right now but
uh
there are people who work on that that
kind of problem i think
we have like relatively simple fixes for
that like rules-based systems that help
make sure that people can't explain
things but i do i do think that there's
a
there's a probably a bunch of open-ended
research questions there about how to
sort of like
make what you're doing you know robust
to when the user gets to set
s in your model and they have some
control over it then you have you don't
have full control over your system
anymore that might be a reasonable way
to think about it
um and so maybe
maybe there's maybe there's some ways to
kind of like provably fix that problem
but
i doubt it i bet that that just adds a
lot of waste
um and as you just mentioned as we have
a question that was actually asked a
while ago
how do you know that your experiment is
a good match for the s values that you
observe
uh i mean so
one of the things so the diagrams that i
showed the state action diagrams are
are like a kind of they're just they're
just theories right they just say like
where could i have done this but they're
not densities
um they're not showing like where you
did collect the data and
one of the interesting things you can do
with that diagram is assess balance
right so
balance would say like how much is the
distribution in this
action similar to that distribution in
this action or you could frame balance
the other way which is given the state
what was the balance between the actions
but really what you care about is the
balance in the state given the action so
we invert that probability distribution
and we can check
that those two distributions are are
similar and you know if they're not
similar enough then it means that there
was something that failed about your
randomization so that people sometimes
call those randomization checks
and uh i know that a lot of researchers
are really interested in like producing
like automated
versions of these checks like maybe
there's ways to verify that your
causal inference system is likely to
work by just checking that you
gather the data that could answer the
question so you can do
positivity which i showed there is
actually like an empirical quantity that
you can you can estimate that you so you
can say like
could my model actually make a
prediction about this was there a
positive probability of ever
observing me doing this with this state
in the past and if it's zero
then your model is gonna it's going to
return an answer because all machine
learning models
produce except for the very honest uh
you know k-means or sorry k-nearest
neighbors
is the most honest model because if it's
if there's a cluster really far away
that
it was sort of like you know there's no
no data nearby it will be very honest
with you but most models won't be honest
they'll just sort of return an answer
so i think like distribution overlap and
whether the distributions are capable of
answering the data that you collected
are capable of answering the questions
that you have is a really fundamental
thing and it's it's
checkable mostly and it just all has to
do with like common support and
intensity which are things you can
estimate
and i know in the past you've been
you've used stand and build some stuff
you know
particularly profit uh if you're doing
bayesian stuff today are you using stan
using pie torch
pie charts have been used for mcnc sort
of yeah
so i i had like emitted variance from
this whole this whole talk
um i love bayesian models i think it's a
really powerful methodology
and you can get a lot out of it it's
also really slow right everybody knows
that
so so you spend a lot of time waiting
and there's a
there's a sort of like uh feedback loop
for researchers right you want to try a
new
model change so you you have to kind of
make move some things around and and
bayesian models are
are very fragile and that you know if
you specify things in an incorrect way
you know they'll they'll find that very
quickly and it's they'll
they'll be wrong but they'll take you a
long time to tell you that they were
and and i think that we just decided
early on to to not pay that cost and
kind of
move a little faster and not actually
deal with uncertainty in a principle way
uh and i i think if i could go back in
time i'm not sure if i would do that
again i think that there are
there are big trade-offs there but i
guess the hope is that
the neural network frameworks like
pytorch start bolting on
better inferential capability over time
and that you can get it for free and not
have to
not have to worry about it so much but
um there's lots of
frequent this kind of uh uncertainty
estimation i had a bullet on my slides
about conformal inference conformal
inference is a very powerful tool
that you can use and you don't need to
um
you don't need to have a full posterior
you can still get like prediction sets
for you know for predictions that you're
making so there's
there are other tools but bayesian
models are just like slow and hard to
hard to scale so we've had some
challenges using them at practice
makes sense all right i do know um
scaling a lot of these neural networks
are um
used on gpus span actually recently is
now able to be worked on the gpu
it's a new feature so and there's the
speed up so dramatic probably not as
fast as you need but that is i'm very
i'm very excited about that
you know i i think that team is amazing
and i
you know they do awesome work and i
still think stan is like the only like
ground truth
like estimated i would always believe
this you know a posterior i get from
stan over like anything i did
myself so it's very valuable to see them
making progress there and i do hope that
someday it's just as fast as anything
else and we don't have to make any
compromises but i think
you know the world as it is is that we
have to like pick somewhere on the
spectrum of
fully bayesian is the most expensive
modeling that you can do it's sort of
like
you know time and effort both are very
expensive for that one
i like that that you're right it's both
time and effort it is over involved
defining your model and doing the
fitting that's actually really great
all right so i think that was
all of the questions i was looking
around to see if anyone's messaged me on
any of the screens i have open
and it looks like that is all of them
so everybody knows where to find me so
you know happy to answer other questions
i should please tell them where to find
you in case anyone doesn't know about
you on twitter anywhere else
yeah you can you can connect with me on
twitter it's just
you know my name but without the period
in it um
and uh and yeah always happy to chat
about this stuff i think it's really
interesting i think
i think it's uh exciting because it's a
bunch of unsolved problems and i'm
really looking forward to like this
becoming
like these ideas becoming a more
full-fledged like part
you know part of data science and i'm
also really looking forward to people
just sort of like learning about
the basics of causal inference and
getting started on it because it's just
like a super fun way to think about
what you work on and think about the
world
right so thank you very much and
everyone please
tag him at sean jay taylor um you know
be in touch let everyone ask me
questions or
just say hi and say thank you um and
i'll say thank you for being here and
thank you for all the cool stuff you
built
and i look forward to one day hopefully
soon seeing you in person
and um have a great time and i'm going
to give you a golf clap on behalf of
everyone else
and hope that everyone enjoyed this as
thoroughly as i did
i see a lot of comments in the in the
comment section saying thank you so
everyone's telling you thank you right
now thanks everybody appreciate your
time too
thanks jared yep and everyone i'll see
you next month
that on august 12th for e cook in
september at the meetup and at the
conference in person
have a good night everybody